[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's
800-463-7297 international pastor doug
batchelor
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact
authorities in sri lanka say the world's
largest star sapphire cluster has been
found in the backyard
by accident
a gem trader said the stone was found by
workmen digging a well behind his home
in the gem rich ratnapura area
the cluster weighs around
1124 pounds or 2.5 million carats and
it's been named the serendipity sapphire
experts say the stone which is pale blue
in color has an estimated value of up to
100 million dollars on the international
market
mr gemmaji the owner of the stone said
the person who was digging the well
alerted us about some rare stones
later we stumbled upon this huge
specimen
he didn't want to give us his full name
or location for obvious security reasons
along with diamonds rubies and emerald
sapphires are considered among the most
valuable gems the huge stone is believed
to be the largest sapphire cluster in
the world
you know pastor ross sapphires are
mentioned more than any other precious
gem in the bible yes pastor i guess
amazing when you think about it i mean
you've got the bible speaking of
sapphires in the second book of the bi
of the bible exodus and then you find
the last book of the bible the book of
revelation again mentions sapphire and i
understand that they one of four of the
most precious stones uh on earth but
also four precious stones spoken of in
the bible that's right yeah and they're
um it's mentioned several times ezekiel
in fact well let's give folks a few
samples his bible answer program let's
use some bible here exodus 24 verse 10
it says when this is not long after the
ten commandments were given and the
people drew near the mountain of god and
they saw the god of israel and there was
under his feet as it were a paved work
of sapphire stone and it was like the
very heavens in its clarity you know
it's like sapphire is a blue
sparkling kind of a heavenly color
and on the high priest he used to wear a
an ephod
and on the iphone or the breastplate
there were 12 stones and every stone was
different and one of those stones is a
sapphire
which is interesting because the bible
also tells us that satan before he was
satan he was a lucifer one of god's
great angels and it tells us that he had
many of the same stones as the high
priest
these beautiful gems that he wore
sapphires mentioned but then when you
get to
revelation and it talks about the
foundation stones of the new jerusalem
it says there are 12 foundations and
each foundation is a precious stone and
of course among them
is a sapphire stone and some people
think well how can that be real gates of
pearl
glorious gem
foundation stones
it is real it's very real and god has
prepared a city you know those things
don't wear away the
pyramids are still here today because
they're made of mineral god is going to
make the new jerusalem out of minerals
that will last forever
and if anyone's wondering about that
place called heaven we've got a book
that i think will encourage you it's got
a lot of scripture in it tell you not
only that heaven is real but how you can
be there
we have a book it's called heaven is it
for real and this is a free offer we'll
be happy to send this to anyone who
calls and asks the number call is
800-835-6747
and you can just simply ask for the book
it's called heaven is it for real we'll
be happy to send that to anyone here in
north america if you're outside of north
america folks can just go to the amazing
facts website and you'll be able to read
the book there online heaven is it for
real you know pastor doug sometimes
people they read the bible's description
of heaven and then they try and
calculate what heaven would be like
based on human terms or worldly terms
then it just seems so
spectacular it's it's beyond belief but
what we need to recognize is that the
bible tells us that we can't even begin
to imagine the things that god has
prepared for those that love him
absolutely
now for our friends that are listening
you may notice that the format of the
program is a little bit different
tonight and that's because we're turning
the corner this is the first time that
bible answers live is now on tv we've
been on facebook and we are still they
can go watch the program on facebook
either the amazing facts facebook page
or the doug batchelor facebook page but
tonight we've added a network we have
it's amazing facts tv and there's
probably folks watching us right now on
amazing facts tv they like to greet all
of you if you're listening on the radio
and you're wondering well amazingfactstv
where do i find that if you have roku
you can actually find it on the roku
system or you can just simply go to
youtube and you type in
that's amazingfactstv you'll be able to
view amazing facts programming on
amazing facts tv there are also other
outlets we satellite well the main one
we started with g19 it's a satellite
that reaches all of north america and
we're still there so you can see us on
galaxy 19 as well all right well before
we get to the program this evening as we
always do we like to start with prayer
so let's do that dear father we thank
you once again for this opportunity to
open up your your word the bible and
study together and father we ask your
blessing upon this program be with the
people who are listening wherever they
are across this country and even in
other places around the world father we
know the greatest and most important
thing for us to do is to come to a
saving knowledge of you through your
word so bless our time today for we ask
us in jesus name amen amen
well pastor doug we do have phone lines
that are open and if you have a bible
related question the number call is
just stay on 800-463-7297 and one of our
call screeners will be happy to take
your call
we have our first caller for this
evening we have
psalm who's listening from massachusetts
some welcome to the program
hi thank you for thanking taking my call
um
i have a question about the four angels
that's around the throne of god
and
you know first of all i wondered if they
if lucifer used to be one of them and
secondly why do they cry out holy holy
holy i know they it appeared in isaiah
chapter six and also revelation chapter
four right i just want to know your
thoughts about these two things okay
you're right the there's only two places
in the bible where it says holy holy
holy three times and you've mentioned
there isaiah chapter six and in
revelation chapter four there's a little
difference in the vision in isaiah 6 it
says there's two seraphim
by the throne that sounds more in
keeping with the two cherubim by the the
throne or the mercy seat in in the ark
of the covenant and in the jewish temple
but when we get to revelation it talks
about the four creatures around god's
throne i think there's more symbolism
being used there now you ask now was
lucifer one of them i think lucifer was
one of the two
covering cherubs by the throne of god
because it says now is it isaiah or
ezekiel it says thou art the anointed
cherub that covereth and either isaiah
14 or ezekiel 28 says that
and there's the two big passages on
lucifer in those sections of the bible
but
in regard to your other question
you know what's the meaning of the four
and why does it say holy holy holy well
some of said that in hebrew when you
want to say something's great you repeat
it
if you say someone's handsome you say he
is handsome handsome if you really
really really wanted to emphasize
something you'd never go beyond three
you'd say they're handsome handsome
handsome strong strong strong
when it says that god is holy holy holy
that means he is perfectly
the perfect definition of holiness in
hebrew they would
emphasize things by repeating it that's
why jesus sometimes said
verily verily i say to you said you
better pay attention sit up this is
going to be very important that passage
yes i was actually going to mention
before we get to that we have a whole
study guide past today talking about the
devil
did god create a devil and it deals with
those passages in isaiah that describes
lucifer before the fall and their refers
to him as a covering cherub and there's
a lot of other bible verses that you can
find so uh if you'd like to receive that
study guide the number to call is
800-835-6747
and just ask for the amazing facts study
guide it's called did god create a devil
it's got all the bible verses there and
then one additional thought pass that i
go about before living creatures it's
interesting when you look at the
description in revelation 4 it says that
they had six wings
and their constant cries holy holy holy
the first is a face like unto a lion the
second likened to a calf the third like
unto a man the fourth like into a flying
eagle and when you look at the
description that we find it uh kind of
helps direct us to help us understand
the ministry of christ he is the lion
he's the king he's the one who came to
bear our sins he's a high priest in
heaven he's coming as an eagle as king
of kings and lord of lords so some
interesting parallels that we see there
in revelation before
thank you for your call our next quarter
that we have is jeff and he's listening
in montana jeff welcome to the program
good evening good evening i wanted to
know
is there any connection or significance
between the annual tribute that solomon
received in first kings 1014 of 666
talents of gold
and the number of the beast in
revelation you know that's a great
question i've wondered that before
i think there's two places in the bible
you find that number
one of them is it it tells us in uh
first kings that there came to solomon
in one year 666 talents of gold
the thing that strikes me about the
mention of that number is
with the reign of david the kingdom was
just doing great it uh israel had
conquered all of their enemies david
subdued all the surrounding nations and
you could go through and name every one
of them he he subdued them they were
paying tribute then solomon becomes king
and everything goes from good to better
he's a godly king he loves the lord all
nations are coming to israel like the
queen of sheba to find out about god
they build the temple of the lord
solomon builds his incredible palace his
his reputation for wisdom is going
around the world
and then it says in one year 666 talents
came to israel and the next chapter says
but solomon loved many women
and from there the kingdom goes down so
it's like the mention of this number
happens
and it shifts from god to man just like
man was made on the sixth day
and so 666 is like the number four it's
the number of a man
and it's talking about man-made worship
from that point on the kingdom just goes
downhill so i thought that's an
interesting it's like a
they turned around a pole and ran the
other direction when they got to 666.
so that's all that i've come up with on
that i think jeff does that make any
sense
yes it does yeah especially when you
talk about the very next chapter yeah
everything turned south right after the
mention of 666 it's amazing
so hey thank you so much that's uh
that's a good point
okay our next quality that we have is
kathleen listening from
arizona kathleen welcome to the program
hi thank you hi pastor doug and pastor
ross
my question is regarding galatians 6
and verse 2 it says bear you on
another's burdens and so fulfill the law
of christ
but then you go down to verse 5 and it
says for every man shall bear his own
word
so it seems to me like it's a
contradiction
yeah well i think what paul is saying is
that when we love our brother it's like
jesus says it and paul says it in
another place
that uh all of commandment is summed up
in this to love your neighbor as
yourself
paul is simply saying that you know when
you really love your neighbor you're
fulfilling the ten commandments at least
the commandments that deal with your
love for your fellow man
but when he says every man will bear his
burden it means that we will all you
know answer to god for um
you know our life and everyone does have
a cross to bear so he's really using the
term i think in in two different ways
there
okay you know jesus said come after me
take up your cross we bear the cross
after christ and i think you'd also add
to that a little bit everybody has a
burden to bear and that's the point that
paul is emphasizing we all have burdens
to bear
therefore
let's help one another we can bear one
another's burden because everyone has
their own burden that they have to bear
true
true okay thank you very much all right
thanks so much
okay next quarter that we have is uh
damon listening from oklahoma city damon
welcome to the program
thank you how you guys doing we're doing
a lot better than we deserve how are you
doing
i'm doing pretty good
and your question today
yeah my question was over
um isaiah 45 7.
um i've seen some atheists try to use
this um in some bibles it says um god
created light and darkness and then it
says and some others it says god created
good and evil and i've seen some
atheists try to use that and say see
there god created evil so i was just
wanting to know how do you guys actually
like break down that verse or does it
pose to say you were there or not
yeah the word when he he says this in
the um
uh that passage there in isaiah isaiah
45 7 he's the verse yeah he's not saying
that god creates evil the word there is
really that he sends judgment
um and it is true that god will send
judgment so
it's talking about when he says evil you
read the the context isaiah is talking
about disasters that were going to come
upon god's people because they turned
away from god and he was going to allow
that
and so in that sense you might say well
you know people think a disaster is evil
but when people turn away from the lord
they reject god they reject his
protection from the devil and so in that
sense he's like you're saying you chase
me away and i'm your hedge of protection
a devil is going to get to you
and even in the story of job
you know the devil said you put a hedge
of angels about him but if you move your
hedge
and i get to touch him he'll curse you
and god says all right i'm going to back
off to show you that you're wrong so
you know that's the big question is is
god
is god
guilty ascending evil when he withdraws
his protection
and you know the lord he did send a
flood on noah so people would say well
is that evil god didn't make evil but he
does judge wickedness
[Music]
does that help damon
i know what you mean i've i've heard
people use the verse that way and and
they want to make it sound like see god
made evil but you can also if they
believe the bible i mean they're reading
the bible to try and prove god made evil
read the part of the bible where it says
every good and perfect gift comes from
god
and you can read in genesis where god
makes the world says everything was good
good very good
and you get to chapter three and men
decided not to believe the word of god
and that's when evil came in
you know we did that study guide we
mentioned it earlier it's called did god
create a devil and it deals with this
question of you know if if god is good
why does he allow bad things to happen
and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks the number to
call for that is 800 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the amazing facts
study guide it's called dead god create
a devil
next holder that we have is alex and
alex is listening from tennessee alex
welcome to the program
hey
hello pastor doug hello pastor john
hi
uh so i had a question and uh i just
found the verse to back it up where in
hebrews 9 22 where it says and almost
all things are by the law a purge of
blood and without shedding of blood no
remission which is usually referring to
sin
so i i was wondering
why do you need to use why did god
require blood for the sacrifices i mean
the remission of sins has there been
some alternative or something yeah well
blood is the is the epitome of an
example of life and it says in the bible
and it's in genesis pastor ross it's in
a couple places i think it may be in
leviticus too the life is in the blood
the life is in the blood and so when the
penalty for sin is death
and uh
when jesus poured out his blood it's
like he gave his life
every single cell in your body is
fed and cleansed by blood and when a
person loses their blood they die
and so it's always become sort of a
symbol that blood was an atonement
because it represented a life
now the jews did not believe in
where people would prick their finger
and you'd use a little bit of blood to
you know become blood brothers i
remember when i was a kid we did that i
don't know where we got the
we heard that's how you become indian
blood brothers we need to prick our
fingers and we touch the blood together
and
and uh
the jews didn't have a ceremony where
you used a little bit of your blood
when you gave your blood it was because
you died they would cut the throat of
the lamb it required a death
and so the blood became a symbol of that
and of course it ties into
the cost of redemption was the blood of
christ meaning the death of christ this
constitutionally death and so through
the sacrificial system sacrificing the
lambs it was all pointing forward to
jesus and and his sacrifice that was to
come
does that help alex
yeah but speaking about the about jesus
dying i've heard some people think that
it's a moral injustice for jesus to die
on the cross instead of us
well think about that yeah i think that
uh it's a sign of the love of god that
he would substitute himself whenever
somebody loves somebody and they say
look i don't want them to suffer i will
take their suffering for them the bible
says no greater love has anyone that
then he would lay down his life for a
friend by the way that verse is
leviticus 17 11 for the life of the
flesh is in the blood
and
it says for um to make atonement for you
for your souls it is in the blood that
makes atonement for the soul that's
probably the best definition there
leviticus 17 11.
but yeah the
it's the justice of god a death was
required he said i will die in your
place
you know we have a book called the high
cost of the cross that talks about the
sacrifice of jesus that's really
inspiring and we'd be happy to send this
book to anyone who calls and asks the
number to call his
800-835-6747 again you can ask for the
book it's called the high cost of the
cross we'll send it to anyone here in
north america if you're outside of north
america you can read it at the amazing
facts website thanks for your call alex
the next quarter that we have is susie
and she's listening from colorado susie
welcome to the program
hi
thank you for taking my call um i just
have one question i want to know
does our name go in the book of life
when we're conceived and then it stays
there until we reject christ
now your name goes in the book of life
when you accept christ because we're all
born in sort of a fallen condition
and
when we turn to christ and we accept
christ you're born again
jesus said he's come to give us eternal
life you don't really receive eternal
life just by being born you receive
eternal life by accepting the sacrifice
of jesus in your behalf
at that point he enters your name in the
book of life
and you know a person you know
sometime in their life they could turn
away from the lord i think moses talks
about
he said take my name out of your book
which you have written
and god says and this is exodus 32 33
the lord said to moses whoever has
sinned against me i will blot him out of
my book in other words among the
believers the children of israel they
accepted the lord but he says if they
turn from him i'll take their name out
of the book it doesn't mean one sin it
means a life of sin you give up on the
lord
and we have a few more verses kind of
interesting paul refers to this in
philippians chapter 4 verse 3 he talks
about his fellow workers whose names are
written in the book of life
revelation 3 5
says that those who are faithful he will
not blot their names out of the book of
life revelation 13 8 says those whose
names have been written in the book of
life they are the ones that will worship
uh worship god so to have your name
written in the book of life is a good
thing it means eternal life yeah
and uh
anyone listening
i'm sorry say that again please
babies that die before they can accept
christ
yeah if the bible's pretty clear that
the children of believers that
they die before the age of
accountability
they're going to be in the kingdom by
virtue of their parents
decision
there's a great mystery and debate in
the world among theologians about
is every baby that is born
or every baby that's conceived are they
all automatically saved they definitely
are not going to be punished but whether
that means they're automatically all
resurrected
uh you know that's a that's a mystery
some believe that yes every baby that is
conceived is going to be in heaven and
then when you do the math though it
seems like
heavens you can be swimming in babies
um
and then there's some who believe that
they may just be go to sleep and be as
though they had not been you're going to
see yeah i was just going to add to that
you know we do have a reference to in
jeremiah chapter 31 verse 16 that's
actually quoted by matthew
and it's referring to the time when the
romans destroyed all of the baby boys in
bethlehem
and the quote from jeremiah 31 16 thus
saith the lord refrain your voice from
weeping in your eyes from tears
for your work shall be rewarded saith
the lord and they shall come back from
the land of the enemy
so the land of the enemy meaning death
here so this is a promise to those
mothers that their children would be
resurrected in the the resurrection of
the second coming of christ so we do
have hope yes a believing parent will
get to see their their children if they
die before the age of accountability
does that help a little susie
yes it does thank you so much all right
thank you
next quarter that we have is uh paul
listening in idaho paul welcome to the
program
good day
hi
hey uh
i have a question now
this uh three angels message
comes in revelation 14 yes
now
why
are we so
um
fearful of showing that
and
why are people not accepting it
you know it's interesting you would ask
that question i was just doing working
on a message today about the three
angels message i'm going to be sharing
this week at a christian convention
in orlando and that's my subject so yeah
right some people are reluctant to share
it for those listening
um our brother here is talking about the
three angels message in revelation 14 it
talks about jesus coming in the clouds
and
um right after jesus is pictured oh
right before jesus is pictured coming in
the clouds it talks about these three
angel messages
in revelation chapter 13 says every
nation kindred tongue and person is
going to be forced to worship the beast
or they can't buy or sell and they'll be
killed revelation 14 it says the gospel
is going to go to every nation kinder
tongue and people so
in the last days these messages of
angels flying into heaven it's a lasting
emphasis of the gospel and the message
of judgment and salvation goes to the
world immediately prior to christ coming
that's why it's a very important present
truth
and of course immediately following the
proclamation of the three angels message
pastor doug you you read about the
second coming of christ in revelation
chapter 14. yeah and of course the
angels i'm sure they are
real angels or angelic angels that
assist in the proclamation of the
message but in a very real sense god's
people are represented by those angels
that are taking that
end time message to the world you know
we do have a study guide talking about
the three angels messages it's called
angel messages from space
and a very important subject found in
revelation chapter 14 we'll send that to
anyone who calls and ask the number
again is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the study guide
angel messages from space it's all about
the three angels messages
all right well thanks for your call
we've got kirk listening in texas kirk
welcome to the program
yes thank you
hi and your question tonight
yes
i have a lot of questions but i guess i
only have time to ask you one
um
did jesus my question is did jesus use
his divine nature to overcome
the temptation or
did he use
his human nature to overcome the
temptation
well jesus ended up using the same power
that is available to you and me every
time he was tempted he responded by
saying it is written it is written
and
we can use that now in the bible you've
got examples of bible characters that
were tempted that fell
you know
solomon and david would be examples of
that and in the bible you've got
examples of human characters that were
victorious
joseph was sorely tempted
by potiphar's wife and job went through
a series of terrible temptations but it
said in all these things he'd sinned not
or did he curse god foolishly
and our charge got foolishly and so
um jesus he he trusted in his father
he's an example for us of how we can
overcome and how others have overcome
man doesn't live by bread alone but by
every word of course that's one of the
responses that jesus gave to the lucifer
when he
was tempted
and you know jesus said in john chapter
5 verse 30 he said i can of myself do
nothing that must have shocked the
disciples but when jesus took upon
himself humanity he laid aside his
divinity in one sense and he trusted in
the strength given to him by his father
even as his disciples and as believers
are to do everything jesus did
he did with the power that is available
to you and me jesus raised the dead but
you can see where the apostles raised
the dead he healed the sick the apostles
heal the sick christ said these miracles
that i've done greater things than these
will you do because i go to the father
so hopefully that answers your question
appreciate that you know we do have a
book it's called tips for resisting
temptation and we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who asks again the number
is 800-835-6747
tips for resisting temptation and
friends you hear the music in the
background it's not the end we're just
taking a break we'll be right back
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
you know that noah was present at the
birth of abraham
ok maybe he wasn't in the room
but he was alive and probably telling
stories about his floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of revelation
biblehistory.com is a free resource
where you can explore major bible events
and characters enhance your knowledge of
the bible and draw closer to god's word
go deeper
visit biblehistory.com
[Music]
amazingfacts offers some of the best
christian resources for all ages we hope
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the lord
what does bible prophecy reveal about
the world's two largest religions
explore the ancient conflict in islam
christianity and prophecy a compelling
three-part series with pastor doug
batchelor
get yours today by calling 800 538
or visit afbookstore.com
what if you could know the future
what would you do
what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a military prodigy
150 years in advance
cyrus had been named
nebuchadnezzar who built the city as a
showcase to the entire world
rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
[Music]
this intriguing documentary hosted by
pastor doug batchelor explores the most
striking bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history
kingdoms in time
an extraordinary adventure through the
bible's most amazing fulfilled
prophecies kingdoms in time dot com
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
[Music]
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live i am pastor doug batchelor
and my name is john ross and as you can
tell from the name this is bible answers
live so if you have a bible related
question we'd love to hear from you the
number to call if you have a bible
question is
we have we have 800-463-7297 calling
from sydney australia we've got uh fidei
listening from sydney
fede welcome to the program
thank you
yes and your question tonight
okay my question okay um the the woman
that sits on the beast with seven heads
yes
can i put my two cents in uh you have a
question or a comment
a comment of the seven heads all right
let's make that brief because most
people are waiting to ask a question i
know i know okay
the the birth ministry and the death of
jesus proved seven false religion
systems were false
so
the seven heads
there's seven mountains seven continents
one says the paganism says god created
by man the second atheism says
there is no god
and the third one is
judaism says salvation comes through
work
and this
fourth one is uh islam salvation comes
through work and the fifth head is
eastern mysticism okay
um god
uh man can become god and one is
catholic and the uh the other head
number seven is salvation comes through
works
so all the their mountains or hills well
ever like let's say the the catholic
around the world look to their mountain
in vatican and
protestant look to the head of
uh capitol hill and the other heads look
to their god mountains yeah that's what
i see and the woman
on the
and the woman that's the woman
that isabelle just like jesus has a
bride the people and jezebel is the
antichrist people okay now do you have a
question
that's what i think that's what i'm
saying all right well
i've never heard that that's uh very
intriguing i would respectfully disagree
but i've honestly never heard that
interpretation before for the seven
mountains that you find in revelation
17.
most people believe it says that that
woman is a great city that reigns over
the kings of the earth when john had his
vision that great city was of course the
kingdom of rome that had imprisoned him
and of course was responsible for the
execution of jesus
and that those it says five of the king
those seven hills are also seven not
only the seven hills of rome rome is
called the city of seven hills
and here you've got a woman it's a
church situated in rome that doesn't
leave any uh questions i would think
but it says that those seven hills are
also seven kings five are fallen
one is one is yet to come he's also the
eighth i'm paraphrasing
and uh people who believe these are the
five empires that have occupied
and persecuted god's people namely egypt
assyria babylon medo-persia greece those
are the five that were fallen when john
had his vision one is rome
was the one that is
and it says he's also the seventh
because it was first pagan rome is the
sixth
papal rome is the seventh papal rome
receives a deadly wound but comes back
again meaning he's also the eighth
no that may not be a perfect
interpretation but it's satisfied me for
several years
so and i think most many protestant
reformers are believed something like
that yes if you go back into the old
testament you notice starting as early
as the book of daniel you find different
beasts representing kingdoms that have
war against god's people you find that
not only in the old testament but of
course in the new testament there was
also persecutions that came upon
christians through various political and
then eventually political religious
powers as you look in history so that's
an interesting study in revelation 17.
thanks for your call next quarter that
we have is stephen listening from canada
stephen welcome to the program
uh hi pastor um doug batchelor and
pastor john ross
nice to be on oh it's good to have you
on
thank you i've watched you guys actually
for a very long time i'm a seventh-day
adventist myself and your question
tonight
um
my question is it says in um chapter 12
of numbers that says and and miriam and
aaron spake against moses because of the
ethiopian woman whom he had married for
he had married an ethiopian woman so my
question is i'm curious it says she's an
ethiopian woman in chapter 12 but why
like back in
numbers chapter like just before chapter
three and in the first uh verse of
chapter three it talks well obviously
because jeffree being the prince of
media or um john jeffros well he's a
media knight his daughter wouldn't of
course naturally be a media
media knight divided saying that
correctly so i'm just wondering why
the seeming contradiction or just
something maybe the way the king james
laid it out i don't know i'm wondering
why
it's a good question yeah it
there's a couple of ways and no one's
absolutely sure
but um
of course moses first meets zipporah a
midianite
the daughter of i think she's the oldest
of jethro's daughters
and he meets her 40 years earlier
he rescues the girls by the well and he
has sons with her she's still alive when
he goes into egypt because there's a
mention of her specifically
later her father-in-law comes and brings
the boys i guess she had gone back
during the ten plagues she'd gone back
to midian and her father then meets up
with the boys and with his wife
a midianite they could easily be called
an ethiopian because it was all the same
territory so many times in the bible
you'll hear a particular
group of people and there's a couple of
different ways they're referenced uh you
know
uh aaron this is an example of miriam
and aaron
they were um they were upset that moses
did not marry a jewish girl even the
midian is related to abraham
she was not
an israelite
and so
there and she may have been darker
skinned
and so they're
they're
exhibiting some frustration and i think
that marion was also feeling slighted
that
god is speaking to her younger brother
and she had been a prophetess and not
talking to her
she was wanting some of the leadership
she wanted to be promoted
so she gets punished through this story
you find here in exodus chapter 12. but
the other theory is that after 40
something years of marriage maybe
a zipporah had died and moses had
remarried which would not be uncommon
because he still had another 40 years to
live so
they're not sure there's nothing in the
bible that says explicitly one way or
the other i'm inclined to think that
they just had two different ways of
referring to zephora one is she's a
midianite the other one says she's the
ethiopian
midian was a tribe ethiopia was kind of
more of a race
in an area yeah they came from all right
well thanks for your call stephen we
appreciate it we've got jonathan
listening in nashville tennessee
jonathan welcome to the program
hey good evening
hi
doing good thank you for calling
all right good to hear hey uh this
question is regarding the book of daniel
um
looking at some of the prophecies on how
some of the other uh
christian faith communities uh look at
how the
kingdoms are run in sequence
uh what do you think where some of the
uh disagreement or where things kind of
diverge and how uh the gap theory and
some of these
seven year tribulations uh what are the
i guess what are the scriptures that
uh that we could point to uh to help us
yeah
by these these kingdoms run in sequence
versus allowing for any gap yeah great
question now i think jonathan's
referring more specifically to daniel
chapter 9 where there's a 490-year
prophecy
and you know all the kingdoms namely
babylon medo-persia greece rome you have
pagan rome papal rome
and then the divisions of the roman
empire they all kind of run in sequence
when you get to daniel 9 he talks about
this 490 year prophecy and then it tells
us that
after 483 years the messiah is cut off
of course in that last seven years
it says in the midst of the week he
causes the sacrifice to cease
that's talking about from the time of
jesus baptism
he ministers three and a half years
he dies on the cross the veil of the
temple is ripped he causes the sacrifice
to cease
he rises from the dead and for three and
a half years he tells the disciples do
not go in the way of the gentiles
continue to preach to the lost house of
israel the time for the jewish nation
had not been cut off yet until the
supreme court of the nation
stoned stephen the sanhedrin
but you know there was a
i think this came in with darbyism
they came in with a futuristic
interpretation that that seven weeks was
not contiguous with the 483 years of
daniel 9. that you could take that seven
weeks and you could float it around in
the end of time somewhere and it was the
seven years of tribulation
you don't find the phrase seven years of
tribulation anywhere in the bible
this is a very in my opinion it is a
very um
free spirited interpretation someone's
just kind of
made this up and they thought it sounded
good and
i you know i've heard people say well
because
noah had to wait in the ark seven days
before the flood that's representing the
the seven last plagues and seven years
of the time of trouble now i think that
this is all one continuous prophecy of
490 years we have a study guide on that
we do i'm actually looking it's called
right on time and it deals with this 490
year time period that you find in the
book of daniel and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
the number to call is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the study guide it's
called write on time and we'll get it to
you in the mail
thank you for your call we've got uh
let's see our next caller we're going to
go to jeff jeff in
willingham or wellington delaware jeff
welcome to the program
hey how you doing it's actually
wilmington wilmington delaware here we
go
well first i want to i want to praise
god for the you for doug batchelor and
yourself your active
involvement in the community because
uh i think
if you look
going back in the past it really is
really something the seventh avenue
church needed to provide and you guys
are doing it so
thank you very much i appreciate it well
thank you and your question tonight
um
i actually have a couple was lucifer an
anomaly
how many men were translated
did angels fornicate with men
and i have two other ones if you want if
you want to hit that well let's that's
the
first of all the one about did angels
have inter intimate relations with men
that often comes from genesis chapter 6
where it says the sons of god saw the
daughters of men that they were fair
and took the wives of all they chose
people think those sons of god are
angels it's not at all what it's talking
about it's talking about the descendants
of seth intermarried with the
descendants of cain
and once they lost that distinction
violence filled the earth we have a book
on that that will send you it's called
angels alien or adopted who are the sons
of god the number to call is
800-835-6747 and again you can ask the
book it's called who are the sons of god
and i'm trying to think was there
another question that jeff had yeah you
asked you threw two or three quick ones
there yeah yeah what are your thoughts
or it was lucifer and anomaly because
you said you said god didn't create sin
so lucifer great is saying was that an
anomaly
well
no
well what i mean by no is god did not
have a defect if you mean uh by anomaly
god made all of his creatures perfect
and it even says in the bible thou was
perfect
in all your ways and part of the
perfection as lucifer was made perfectly
free
and in his perfect freedom he was able
to choose whether to love god supremely
or to start loving himself more and
lucifer became involved in self-worship
he didn't want to worship god he wanted
to be god says thou has said in thy
heart i will be like the most high
he god is so free
that he will even make a creature that
can choose not to love him
and so lucifer by his own free choice uh
rebelled against god and that of course
reminds me of that free offer we have
it's called did god create a devil and
it deals with the subject the number to
call for that is
800-835-6747 ask for the study guide did
god create a devil thanks for your call
jeff we're going to go to uh yolanda
listening in arizona yolanda welcome to
the program
hi hi how are you doing i'm good how are
you
yeah doing great and your question
tonight
okay so i have first of all i'd like to
tell you guys thank you so much for
amazing facts it was five years ago that
i heard one of your sermons and i i've
heard i heard things that that that i've
never heard before so i want to thank
you for
for for uh amazing facts and to to
teaching the truth thank you so much
yeah it's our pleasure okay so my
question is in genesis chapter 4
verses 23 and 24 with lamech
where it says hear my voice the wives of
lamech hearken unto my speech for i have
slain a man to my wounding
and a young man to my heart
if cain shall be avenged sevenfold truly
lamech 70 and sevenfold i don't know
what that means yeah well it's going
through the genealogies and it just
highlights this incident about lamech
and i think one reason it mentions it is
first of all it's the first mention of
polygamy he has more than one wife it's
not his wife it says his wives
and he says ada and zilla hear my voice
wives of lamech listen to my speech
and the way it's worded in the king
james is a little confusing new king
james says for i've killed a man for
wounding me
and a young man for hurting me so now
cain killed abel with no provocation
abel did not attack cain cain killed him
and premeditated cold-blooded murder
here lamech is saying i killed a man
but if cain's going to be avenged
sevenfold because he did it
pre-meditated i did it in self-defense
then i'll be avenged 70 times sevenfold
and it's it's giving you a sample of
where you read later in genesis 6
violence was filling the land
it says that it specifically mentions in
genesis 6 that there's just violence and
the men's thoughts thoughts were only
evil continually and here you've got in
this one passage you've got
polygamy or adultery and
murder and violence so it's telling me
that things were going south quickly
so hope does that help a little yolanda
yes it does thank you so much thank you
appreciate your calling
we've got joy listening from the bronx
in new york joy welcome to the program
thank you thank you for taking my call i
would like to know who's the chief
musician
you're talking about in the psalms
yes
yeah i think at one point when they they
had the sanctuary maybe even before the
temple of moses david had um
he had organized musicians david of
course was a very accomplished musician
he not only played the harp it says he
made instruments i don't know if he gave
instruction on how they were to make him
but he had he was very skilled in doing
it so much so the king brought him to
his palace to sing into play
and so david had a love for music he set
up a choir that was to praise god in the
temple and he had a chief choir director
and it's called the chief musician the
first one that i think is mentioned is
asaph if i'm not mistaken and you'll see
there are several psalms that are
written
by asaph not all the psalms were written
by david in the book of psalms i think
david wrote about 71 or 75 of them
and so some of these songs may be
compositions that were written by david
and for the chief musician to then
instruct the the levites and the singers
to sing and of course these psalms are
used many many years after david yeah so
you'd have different chief musicians
that would be in that role in the
sanctuary the music conductor that's
right yeah he's the chief conductor
all right well thank you for your call
that's a good question thanks um
joy our next call is alex listening in
chicago alex welcome to the program
hi thank you so much for calling uh
picking my call uh our pastor
uh both doctors um
basically i have a question in terms of
um marriage and what i can uh what book
i can look to especially in corinthians
what verses i can use um
in terms of
whether i should stay in a relationship
or i should leave a relationship
where um i'm of a specific denomination
from deafness and he is not and i wanted
to know what are some signs god can be
telling me to leave a relationship
well you know in the bible there are
only a couple of examples
for
just or biblical grounds for divorce one
of those being where jesus says in
matthew chapter 19
and i think it's also in matthew chapter
says
what god has joined together let not man
put asunder
saving for the cause of fornication so
if a spouse
you know moves in with someone else and
has an adulterous affair
that's uh grounds for divorce it doesn't
mean there has to be divorce if there's
repentance and there can be
reconciliation that's always better i
mean you think about all the times that
god's church has according to the bible
it says the people of god have played
the harlot against god and yet he comes
after us if you read the book of hosea
it tells that story the other example
you mentioned corinthians in first
corinthians chapter 7
they had a specific situation where you
know paul was preaching to these roman
pagans they don't worship god
and if one of them accepted jesus so
you've got this
the greco-roman pagan and they worship
jupiter and all these gods and then they
accepted christ they got rid of idolatry
well their spouse was so upset they said
look i i didn't sign up for this i
married you i thought we were in the
same religion now you've left and become
a christian i'm leaving you
paul said we'll try to get them to stay
if they can
if they choose to leave then let them
depart in peace so he mentions a
specific case there he's not talking
about when you know two believers
um
well he just you know are have
irreconcilable differences they're
married they've got to work it out
so um
you know hopefully that gives you some
background by the way that's in first
corinthians chapter seven you'll find
most of that there now alex were you
also asking about about dating or or
marriage
um as far as i'm aware there is no
mention of dating in the bible or at
least new testament
new testament
so i wanted to know um i guess
does god give you hints on whether to
stay or or leave a relationship
especially when this person is making it
hard or um asking for a break and um
yeah no no staying uh
faithful
yeah there if uh if you're married then
you know i we don't ever recommend a
person stays in an abusive relationship
there should be separation hopefully
counseling
but marriage is very serious business
and it's a covenant and if you've made
that covenant of course before marriage
the bible does tell us in second
corinthians chapter 6 14 not to be
unequally yoked and maybe this is what
your question is also referring to alex
if if we're in a dating relationship or
a courtship type of relationship with an
unbeliever or somebody who might you
know be a christian but they their
beliefs are quite different than than
your beliefs well the bible does give us
counsel on that and you know it's going
to be a challenge to have a strong
healthy marriage
if you have people believing things
differently
um you know you have all kinds of
questions that arise when children come
along are they going to go to which
parents church and uh there's all kinds
of issues so the counsel that we have in
the bible is do not be unequally yoked
with unbelievers yeah now we have a book
that i've written on the subject of uh
marriage it's called marriage divorce
and remarriage and we'll send you or
someone else that might be wanting bible
answers on that a free copy the number
to call for that is
800-835-6747 and again the book is
called marriage divorce and remarriage
uh we'll send that to anyone in north
america all you have to do is call that
number
we've got somebody calling from south
korea let's see if i can pronounce his
name we have
jawa from south korea welcome to the
program
oh thank you so much for pronouncing my
name just right it's my first time
calling
welcome oh my question is yep my
question is
my friend believes that china and
america are two fighting dragons
uh according to the his understanding of
the book of and
daniel and revelation
uh well i don't see it in the bible
what's your take on that
yeah you know it's a common belief that
because you look in the world today and
people think of a lion they think of
great britain and the eagle they think
of the us and
almost internationally because the
dragon is a big part of chinese
festivities people think that the dragon
is china in prophecy when it talks about
the dragon it had nothing to do with
china china was not known as the dragon
in bible times
the dragon in bible prophecy is talking
about the devil and revelation 12 it's
more specifically talking about the
devil working through the roman empire
when the dragon sought to devour the
man-child that's when the
the devil tried to destroy jesus as a
baby in bethlehem
and so we've got a whole study that
talks about that but yes
folks i believe
china may be mentioned prophecy but it's
not the dragon in prophecy and we do
find that america mentioned in the book
of revelation it's actually the second
beast power that you read about in
revelation chapter 13. but we're not the
eagle no we're not the eagle there
so
can't use those modern those modern uh
what do you call icons anymore yeah all
right well thanks for your call we're
going to go and we can offer him that
lesson on american prophecy oh that's a
good one yes again if you're outside of
north america which you are just go to
the amazing facts website and you can
read the study guide it's called america
in prophecy if you're in north america
the number to call is 800-835-6747
as for the study guide american prophecy
we've got uh let's see lynn listening in
michigan lynn we have just a couple
minutes before we take a quick break
yes hello gentlemen i have a very quick
question
um
god created light right off the bat
i'm just wondering
in the war in heaven and the time before
he created light
i can't believe it was dark
then
i don't know
maybe they had a different sensory
system
but if light wasn't created till
earth time
was it dark in the war in heaven no
because you can read in first john 1
verse 5
it says this is the message we have
heard from him and declare to you that
god is light and in him is no darkness
at all so when god came to this corner
of the universe and began creating just
by his coming here he said let there be
light he his presence glows i mean moses
came away from the presence of god and
moses was glowing kind of like that
radioactive clock you used to hold to
the light and then you turn off the
lights it glowed for a little while
through exposure to god moses was
glowing so when god came to this
darkened part of the cosmos he said let
there be light and he began to divide
the day from darkness just by i think
spinning the earth
and whatever side was facing him was day
because he doesn't make the sun
until the fourth day
so
in heaven you know god's glory and light
is there and you read in revelation it
says there is no need of the sun in the
city of god for the lord god illuminates
the city in heaven and when you read the
different descriptions of heaven that
the prophet saw in the bible they speak
about the glory and the brilliance and
just the majesty of the presence of god
the light shining forth from god when
the children of israel were in the
wilderness and the shekinah glory the
presence the visible presence of god was
revealed there in the tabernacle in the
sanctuary there was a light a glorious
light and of course when god gave the
ten commandments of mount sinai there
was thundering and light and uh just
great majesty yeah the presence of god
is uh bible says the wicked are
destroyed by the brightness of his
coming
and so
god is light in him is no darkness at
all now listening friends because this
is our first time broadcasting on
amazing facts television and we have
some other networks i think are going to
be carrying the program soon our closing
clock is a little different you don't
want to go away we're signing off our
friends listening on satellite radio but
we are coming back with a bonus bible
question it's a very interesting
question so stay tuned we'll be back for
our final question
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
[Music]
hello friends welcome back for our bible
answers live bonus question for those of
you joining us at the amazing facts
television channel also watching on
facebook or listening on the other radio
stations
we from time to time get people calling
in or writing in with a bible question
we've got an interesting question that
came from a gentleman by the name of
eric and he is writing from florida and
pastor here's this question he says
first of all he talks about himself
mentioning that one of the things he
does is he is a ghost hunter so i guess
he investigates these paranormal type of
things happening
he says also that he knows that we're
not to communicate with the dead but his
question is
my main question is can i be a christian
and be a ghost hunter is that possible
well if you're a christian i would think
you'd want to be a jesus hunter amen why
would you want to hunt for ghosts
first of all some people think that
ghosts are the spirits of dead people
that are haunting but the bible is very
clear the living know they'll die the
dead know not anything and you can read
in the book of job and i think it's
chapter 14 it says when a man dies his
sons come to honor he doesn't know
anything of it he does not return to his
house to go haunt his house
and so um the ghosts that people think
they're seeing are typically
fallen angels sometimes called evil
spirits in the bible that are posing as
the dead and you've got an example of
that in i believe it says at the end of
first samuel
where
you know saul goes to see the witch of
endor and
this evil spirit impersonates
through a medium
the dead prophet and as a result of
going
trying to consult with the dead
saul ends up losing the battle
his three sons die and he commits
suicide the next day along with his
armor bearer it didn't end well the lord
says have nothing to do with a
necromancer and that means somebody who
is consulting with the debt you know we
do have a study guide talking about this
he's got an intriguing title that says
are the dead really dead and it talks
about the subject you know it's
important passed today that we
understand this because we know in the
last days the devil is going to do
everything he can to deceive and i think
one of his deceptions is dead loved ones
appearing and saying things that would
contradict the bible that'll confuse
folks you know we also have another
website called
ghosttruth.com and i we know some of our
friends are writing in questions or in
prison they may not have access to the
internet but for those of you that do
you can just go to ghosttruth.com
and that website gets a lot of traffic
around halloween hey friends we've run
out of time for our bible answers
program for this week but god willing
we're going to be back together with you
again next week we hope that you'll tell
your friends to tune in now on aftv as
well as these other stations god bless
[Music]
you